so I apologize that this circle over
here is not especially circular it's not
my best work but I had to do my best
because I need these circles to touch
now we're gonna prove a property about
these do you remember though do you
remember what was our definition for
what is it what makes circles touch at
exactly one point I gave you a really
technical fancy definition for it does
anyone remember it had to do with
tangents now I just want you to store
that in the back of your mind see if you
could remember it we'll come back to it
in a second
can you take those two centers which
you've actually drawn in and go ahead
and join up the two centers can you do
that join up the two centers okay so
these two centers here I'm going to call
them X and Y when you enjoyed them up
you should notice that the interval XY
seems to pass directly through that spot
where they touch do you notice that if
you actually drew a proper circles how
are you going yet you okay if you
actually drew proper circles you should
find oh if we give this guy a name what
would you like to call this point of
contact but I don't like it I'll tell
you what sorry just before we move on
I'm going to resist calling it or
because it doesn't seem to be the center
of a circle at the moment I'm probably
going to avoid calling it Z as well
because when you say like say a b c d or
PQRS or XYZ you're probably trying to
pick out three or four features that are
all the same kind of feature like you
know PQRS that are all can say click or
PQRS that are all you know that kind of
thing this point seems to be different
from the others
right okay that'll do okay
so X KY seems to be a straight line X KY
seems to be a straight line okay now my
question to you is if it is a straight
line how can we prove that that is
the case okay now I want you to jot down
on the side here a straight line and I
actually want you to think for a moment
and braced on with the people next to
you because you're used to being told
that something is a straight line and
they're using that to prove other kinds
of properties right but what you don't
see very often is you don't know whether
something is a straight line and your
job is to prove that it is so I'm going
to give you a minute or two to brace on
with the person next to you of people
around you what are the things you know
about straight lines what properties do
you know and can any of them be used in
Reverse however think about it together
before you shout out I want you there
some type of thing okay I gave you a
second I gave you more than a second
what properties do we know about
straight lines that we can use here any
suggestions okay so by definition a
straight line is a is two points join
together but what we have is this third
point and we're so we're kind of trying
to say that these two points of these
two points they end up for being one big
line right
okay so we'll keep that in the
background heads what else could you
tell me about straight lines yep I think
yeah I can't what about 180 degrees the
angle sum of a straight line because a
straight line can be thought of as an
angle right the angle sum of all the
angles on there is 180 degrees okay good
what asked you tell me what else that's
okay thank you is there really nothing
else come on you do it lots of things
must realize what is straight beam what
makes for example what makes this
straight and not this straight how could
you describe this hmm you know the
dictionary or it's like what is a line
it's an object that is linear what is
Lydia adjective describing a line you're
like okay fine helpful maybe it might
help if for example I put things like
this on here
and compare this which is a straight
line with this which is not if I said to
you okay let's say that's an X if I put
this over the top what language can use
this yeah hmm okay that's fancy isn't it
so when you have a look at this guy
right we know what gradient is gradient
is a measure of what it's a measure of
steepness slope right so you're like
okay if I measure anywhere along here
like say rise over run you have a look
at that rise over run on this straight
line that rise over run should be the
same as this rise over run or this rise
over this should all be the same right
which is something quite markedly
different over here this rise over this
run is different to this rise over this
run and everywhere you go you get a
different gradient right so how could
you describe what's going on here how
could you hmm yeah what do you reckon ah
okay so wait where's the angle you're
describing where you're talking about
but we wonder what so this angle here X
and K I need three points for an eagle
right like a I need like an A and a B
you need to see so where's the angle
you're referred to what am I going to
fall the angle with so X and K so X and
K can be two points but I need a fed
point for an angle Y so like if I drew
it like this I'm trying to prove that
that angle there is actually zero is
that the idea I I see what you're
getting at it's like maybe it's the
other way around I think X is the end
isn't it like KX y like that sort of
thing maybe I'll swap those around that
that would sort of work we actually did
we played a trick like that with getting
an angle toward zero if your ever won
I'd prove we proved in the sky which
over this
that the tangent is perpendicular to the
radius we actually did exactly what
Roger suggested we took this diagram
which is not a tangent but a what's this
guy called it's a secant because it cuts
right so we said hey hey look if you
take this secant and you move it over to
become a tangent like so then this angle
in here it actually narrows in right it
narrows in and then eventually it's so
narrow it becomes zero like we're
talking about but that is quite hard to
conceptually work with isn't it circles
we know how to represent circles on
Cartesian planes don't we how do you
represent a circle you guys have done
this in the graphs topic this is like
lusts last month or so how do you
represent a circle on the Cartesian
plane you could use an equation country
what kind of equation could you use yeah
you could for instance yeah x squared
plus y squared right equals yeah the
radius squared that would be a circle
with its center at the origin right how
would you move that around because these
circles both don't have the same Center
this is this circle is going to have its
center somewhere else so how would I
shift it over yeah you do something like
this like X minus whatever and Y -
whatever equals some different radius
okay so you could do some work with
those right it does seem a little
complicated though right it seems like
bringing your Bob to a water fight or
something like that so can we use the
fact that we already know for example
you giving me this has anyone gonna hear
how we could use that fact to prove that
X K Y is a straight line or that X K Y X
K and y are curly oh wait actually
Desmond cuz they all wanna construct
anything any ideas for construction
workers
okay so I gave you this clue right at
the beginning I said do you remember our
definition for circles that just touch
is that they share a tangent at their
point of contact right so if they share
at agent I should be able to draw a
tangent okay and its attention to both
circles can you do that for me grab your
ruler out if you have it already like so
so this guy is the common tangent let's
call this tangent let's give it a name
let's call it something like say a B so
now everything here is named what can
you tell me out some of the angles that
we've now created by putting this
tangent in place what can you tell me
okay so so from over here right I know
we'll name an angle for me that's 90
degrees and give me the reason why angle
a sorry a K Y so that's this guy over
here you're suggesting that's 90 degrees
and the reason is the tangent is
perpendicular to what what is it
perpendicular to what's what is KY it's
the rate it's not just any radius though
like I've got all these info two radii
here I haven't drawn what's special at
this one it's at the point of contact
right the radius at the point of contact
the tangent is perpendicular to the
radius at the point of contact okay cuz
yeah as we just pointed out there's lots
of radii here that I could draw up down
left right
but it's only perpendicular that
specific one okay
well that's nice where you're going to
go with this ah so I could say similarly
because it's actually exactly the same
reason I'm going to use just in a
different circle similarly a K X is also
equal to 90 degrees so now we can use
this fact right we didn't know that it
was a straight line before but now I
could say
therefore angle a K y plus angle a K X
is 180 degrees right from these two
facts here but this angle here this is
two adjacent angles right so if they're
adjacent then they add up to this angle
here X K Y that is literally the two
angles that make up this one that's 180
which makes this a straight angle it's a
straight line okay therefore X okay and
Y are Co video and the reason is that
the angle sum of a straight line is 180
so it's kind of nice we're not used to
using these facts in Reverse we're using
the converse is what we would say is but
this is a classic example of knowing
facts but just not not not being used to
using them in a sort of different
orientation that's a key mathematical
skill